my gosh guys think about naja every
single day every single day
naja
was something so good so close and what well
was a hug
the for speed my loved tube was he already
knew the skyline of the nih and you so
funny and she had the  most beautiful
smile
bike de memories driver of such a
wonderful great memories of family show
is bills house which my fair beautiful
by law beg
guacamole that de camino for for holiday
gathering
hails remember in about domino
remember nothing corima has been bel die
was  number so dating almost in china
have yesterday baby
really great time she was always so
dependable
just on loving funny
wonderful giving eye is kidding
spear
and yes
[Music]